I've said a lot of times I don't
remember the number that we just can't
afford to wait until the week before a
major election to call out voter
suppression and voter purges and I'm
trying to make good on that and today
we're ten and a half 11 months out from
the election and we have news once again
that Georgia Republicans are purging
hundreds of thousands of voters from the
voter rolls they did this in the lead-up
to the 2018 election in Georgia you
might remember this at least played a
role I won't say it was the factor that
denied Democratic gubernatorial
candidate Stacey Abrams the win but it
played a role in her not winning that
election and once again we have the
Georgia Republican Secretary of State
Brad reference Berger purging voters by
the hundreds of thousands and a federal
judge has decided this week that they
can go ahead and remove 300,000 voters
that they say are inactive now of course
you might say well you know inactive it
sounds like dead people people who move
to other states and are voting elsewhere
they should be removed from voter rolls
right very very wrong more than a
hundred and twenty thousand of those
300,000 people who are being removed are
being removed merely because they've not
voted for a while this is not a good
reason to remove them and this will lead
to people who do want to vote in
November who are notified about their
removal at an old address and they might
want to vote to remove and remove Donald
Trump in November and they will show up
and be told sorry you're not registered
in Georgia you were allowed to register
to vote only until the fifth Monday
before Election Day that means if you
don't realize you've been purged until
Election Day you're out of luck and
you're not going to be able to vote now
let's look at the numbers a little bit
300,000 voters that's four percent of
the Georgia electorate in 2016 Donald
Trump one in Georgia fifty two forty
five that's five points if it's closer
this time around it might only be a two
or three point margin in Georgia and
we are talking about removing four
percent of the electorate by purging
them due to inactivity a bad faith actor
could strategically purge only so-called
inactive voters that they determine
based on geography or for other reasons
are more likely to be Democratic voters
rather than Republican voters and could
at least hypothetically swing an
election with these voter purges
meanwhile it's not just Georgia I know
this is happening in a lot of states
today all hi I've highlighted Georgia
already something similar is happening
in Wisconsin Wisconsin you might
remember was a key state in 2016 a
Wisconsin was one of the states that
pushed Trump to an electoral college
victory with a combined 75 thousand
votes across only three states Wisconsin
is purging 234 thousand voters this is 7
percent of the electorate there remember
that in Wisconsin
Trump won not by 5 but by 0.77% it was
just 22,000 votes they are purging more
than 10 times the margin of victory in
2016 234 thousand voters so what the
hell do we do there's the individual
level and then there's the systemic
level at the individual level number one
check your status and check it often we
have a link in the description for the
YouTube clip for this story but you can
also find it by googling usa.gov confirm
you're registered to vote they have a
page called confirm that you're
registered to vote at usa.gov which will
show you how to do it keep checking it
you if you is it usa.gov or com now I'm
forgetting I'm sure you can find the
page if you notice that you're not
registered get registered big picture
we've got to end this concept of voter
registration the concept at its core
should be eliminated number one we
should be automatically registering
everybody when they get a driver's
license or take other actions but that's
not even really the solution the big
picture is if you're 18 years old you
should just be registered automatically
the concept of registration is what
needs to be done away with in many
countries this is the way it works
you're a citizen
oh you just show up and vote you don't
have to have registered you don't have
to have filled out a form you don't have
to have told someone I am signaling my
intent to vote at some point in the
future if you are a citizen you can vote
Trump says Democrats can't win without
impeachment they can't win without dirty
dossiers or other techniques that are
untoward subterfuge of different kinds
it really seems like it's Republicans
who know they can't win without voter
suppression who know they can't win if
they don't work to reduce the number of
people that ultimately will vote and it
is well underway so I it's it were ten
and a half months away we know that the
number of stories about voter
suppression will ramp up close to the
election the Georgia voter suppression
story in 2018 only got significant
coverage in like the six weeks before
and it was too late and it was a big
part of why Stacey Abrams lost that
gubernatorial election let's start now
we should all be checking our
registration status we should all be
activists you know I talked earlier in
the show it's actually kind of a good
segue into it about the 600-plus rallies
that took place yesterday in favor of
Donald Trump's impeachment it's great I
love seeing a national national turnout
in this way on a relatively short notice
to activate for or against different
things and yet in this case for the
impeachment of Donald Trump I've said
before we really need mass rallies in
this country we need mass rallies in
urban centers we need to consider other
activism techniques that are go that are
beyond faxing your member of Congress or
signing an online petition when it comes
to voter suppression this is one of the
foremost issues of our time when we talk
about the climate when we talk about
inequality when we talk about voter
suppression voter suppression our
ability to even decide who it is that
will represent us on all of those other
issues it is one of the most important
things that we can do and we need
activism around it and I hope that we
will see it one of our sponsors is
privacy calm they're giving you five
dollars when you sign up for their
completely free service at privacy calm
slash Pakman I've been using privacy for
a little
over a year now you've heard me talk
about it before it's a lifesaver and
here's how it works takes just a couple
of minutes to set up anytime you buy
something online or on the phone instead
of actually using your real credit card
number the privacy app and the browser
plugin let you give each company a
randomized virtual credit card number
that you create out of thin air it'll
even autofill the card number with one
click and the payment is taken out of
your checking account without the
merchant ever knowing your real
information so this allows you to keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create up to 12 of these virtual credit
cards a month you can set spending
limits you can freeze them you can
delete them any time you want so when
you do this it means you're not going to
be charged when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number right after using it which for
instance I love using free trials
because I know I won't be charged when
the trial is over if I use a virtual
credit card number you're keeping your
identity private by not telling
companies who you are you're keeping
your bank or credit card info protected
against data breaches and identity theft
and it's free there's no catch
whatsoever but if you want privacy also
offers a $10 a month plan that gives you
one percent cashback and lets you create
36 credit cards a month and a $25 a
month plan tailored more for small
businesses where you can create 60 card
numbers a month and much more but
definitely go ahead and at least get
started with the free plan you'll
protect your financial info companies
can't charge you unexpectedly and like I
said you'll get $5 to spend when you
sign up at privacy calm / Pakman